-Last night saw
the first major elections
of the Trump era,
and Democrats won big,
trouncing Republicans
in New Jersey and Virginia.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right.
Democrats had major victories
in the governor's races
in New Jersey
and Virginia last night,
which means it's cool
to be a Democrat again.
Right, new New Jersey --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Isn't that right, new New Jersey
governor, Phil Murphy?
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God.
Democrats are such nerds.
He looks like
he just won a chess meet.
[ Laughter ]
But, hey, at least New Jersey
finally has a governor
who can catch air.
[ Laughter ]
But Democrats
can be forgiven a little
awkward enthusiasm because
they've spent the last two weeks
absolutely freaking out over
the governor's race in Virginia,
where it seemed like
Republican Ed Gillespie
was gaining ground
on Democrat Ralph Northam
by running a Trump-inspired,
race-baiting campaign.
Pundits a day before the race
were already gloomy,
like this panel
on "Morning Joe,"
during which, Mika Brzezinski
could not contain her panic.
-We're gonna go around
the table now.
-Oh, no.
-Elections tomorrow.
Let me just start
with this question.
-I don't know.
-Does anybody here think
that the Democrats
are gonna win the governorship
in Virginia tomorrow?
-I don't know, and I'm alarmed
that this is a question.
-What about you?
-I don't think so.
-And is it
the Donna Brazille stuff?
What is turning people
at the last second?
-Do you think Ed Gillespie
or Northam wins?
-It doesn't look like
Northam wins.
-Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
-You got to love
how Mika sounds in that clip,
like she just heard
some dirty gossip about a friend
while holding a glass
of Pinot Grigio.
"Oh, my God!
With the pool boy?!"
[ Laughter ]
So, even before
the results came in last night,
Democrats were certain
they didn't have a chance,
which of course is how you know
they actually had a chance.
They won, but at least
the Democrats were wrong again.
In fact, Democrats went on
to victory in several states,
first, in New Jersey,
where Murphy, the Democrat,
overwhelmingly won the race
to replace
GOP governor Chris Christie.
Christie is so unpopular
in New Jersey that,
on election day,
he found himself bickering
with a voter on the street
over a local issue,
merging a township and a borough
after he cast his ballot.
-Anything else?
Sure, ma'am!
Why not?
Yeah.
'Cause I can't.
-In eight years.
Well, as governor, I can't.
-So, why didn't you?
-I can't.
I understand.
You're so frustrated.
And you know what?
The easiest thing in the world--
The easiest thing in the world
is to stand where you stand
and stand on the sidelines
and critique.
Run for the township committee
of Mendham Township
and be the voice to do it.
No, I know,
'cause that's too hard.
It's easier --
It's easier to sit here --
It's easier to sit here
and complain.
-It's whose hand
in whose pocket.
-It's easier to sit --
-And I don't have
the money like you.
-Oh, really, I'm sure.
I'm sure.
Easier to sit here and complain.
But you know what?
That's the joy
of public service.
It's serving folks like you that
is really such a unique joy.
-Man, it's nice that success
hasn't changed Chris Christie.
You know, the best thing about
Christie living in New Jersey
is knowing he'll never be able
to go anywhere in public again
without someone
giving him [bleep]
[ Laughter ]
"Hey!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, Governor,
I got a bridge right here!
Let me raise it for you!
There you go.
There's another one over there.
There you go."
[ Cheers and applause ]
"There you go.
You can cross from New Jersey,
right over to
go [bleep] yourself.
There you go."
[ Cheers and applause ]
And that wasn't the only
big result in New Jersey.
There was also the case
of a local Republican official
named John Carmen who mocked
the Women's March in January
with a Facebook meme that said,
"Will the women's protest
be over in time
for them to cook dinner?"
And that inspired first-time
candidate Ashley Bennett
to run against Carmen,
and last night, Bennett won.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So now John Carmen will be home
in time to make dinner.
[ Laughter ]
Though he doesn't look like
he'd nail it.
"Good news, honey.
I made fire bread."
[ Laughter ]
Democrats also had big wins
in Philadelphia,
where a civil rights lawyer
who defended
Black Lives Matter activists
just became district attorney,
and in Maine,
where voters overwhelmingly
approved a ballot measure
to expand Medicaid
over the objections of their GOP
governor Paul LePage.
LePage vetoed the Medicaid
expansion five times
in support of President Trump's
attempts to repeal Obamacare.
In fact, LePage made his name
by telling voters
he would fight Obama's agenda
tooth and nail.
-Well, last night, Maine voters
told LePage, "You first."
[ Laughter and applause ]
And let's not forget
New York City,
where the result, a win for
Democratic mayor Bill de Blasio,
was essentially guaranteed.
But there was
an especially fun wrinkle
in the fate
of former Fox News pundit
and Trump supporter Bo Dietl,
who ran against de Blasio
and has a history
of making racist comments.
Dietl got crushed last night,
which might've had something
to do with his closing message,
a bizarre video
of him dancing on the subway.
-♪ No curses in my verses ♪
♪ Didn't have time
to rehearse this ♪
♪ We just came
to uplift your mind ♪
♪ Scratch the surface ♪
♪ Go ahead, Bo ♪
♪ Tell 'em what you know ♪
♪ All I know,
I love the street music ♪
♪ When I become mayor,
there'll be more street music ♪
Man, you got to love
New Yorkers.
They know the first rule
of an asshole on the subway is,
ignore him
and hope he goes away.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
And with Bo Dietl, it worked.
"Hey, I'm running for mayor.
You guys want
to watch my dance?"
[ Laughter ]
And Dietl has not been handling
his loss very well.
This morning, he took to Twitter
to attack the chairman
of a third party
that refused to endorse him,
tweeting,
"Good morning, Frank Morano.
I lost last night, but I'm still
a multimillionaire.
You're still a fat loser
in the loser Reform party.
And you know
you're the real loser
when you can't even
spell the word "loser."
[ Laughter and applause ]
But by far, the biggest rout
was in Virginia,
and even aside
from the governor's race,
Democrats had
a huge night there.
For example, a transgender woman
named Danica Roem
was elected
to the Virginia state house,
becoming the first transgender
lawmaker in the country.
And not only that,
she beat a Republican incumbent,
Bob Marshall, who sponsored
a transgender bathroom bill
and once referred to himself
as Virginia's "chief homophobe."
He also refused to debate Roem
and referred to her
with male pronouns.
The best part of Roem's victory
was her response
when she was asked
if she had anything
to say about Marshall
after she beat him.
Roem said,
"I don't attack my constituents.
Bob is my constituent now."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Damn.
She threw so much shade,
his face turned even whiter.
[ Laughter ]
Virginia's also elected
the state's
first two Latina lawmakers,
and in a truly shocking result,
a Marine veteran,
who calls himself
a Democratic Socialist,
upset one of
the most powerful Republicans
in the Virginia
House of Delegates.
Republicans got beat
so bad in Virginia,
last night,
even the statue of Robert E. Lee
was chased out of town.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
By, apparently,
a very slow mob.
[ Laughter ]
And that's what's
especially interesting
about last night's results
in Virginia,
because Gillespie very much
ran a Trump-inspired campaign
that openly embraced Trump's
racial-grievance politics.
He aired ads connecting Northam
to the MS-13 gang
and sanctuary cities,
sent out mailers attacking
kneeling NFL athletes,
and made keeping up Virginia's
Confederate statues
a centerpiece of his campaign,
with ads like this one.
-For governor,
there's a clear choice.
Ralph Northam wants to take down
Virginia's Civil War monuments.
-I will do everything that I can
to remove the statues
at the state level.
Remove the statues
-Ralph Northam
will take our statues down.
Ed Gillespie will preserve them.
-I'm for keeping them up,
and he's for taking them down,
and that's a big difference
in November.
-November of 1866?
[ Laughter ]
Trump, of course,
enthusiastically embraced
Gillespie's
race-baiting campaign,
tweeting that
"Northam is fighting
for the violent MS-13 killer
gangs and sanctuary cities"
and that Gillespie
"might even save
our great statues/heritage."
Well, you'll never guess
how Trump feels about Gillespie
now that he's lost.
Last night, he tweeted,
"Ed Gillespie worked hard
but did not embrace me
or what I stand for."
Don't worry, Ed.
Trump's only upset because
the election is still fresh.
The good news is,
in Virginia, when you lose,
150 years later,
you get a statue.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Of course,
this is just one election night,
and there's still
a long way to go,
but last night's results
were promising
for a Democratic party
in desperate need
of something to give them hope.
And if there's one thing
Democrats are good at,
it's celebrating victories.
♪♪
Scratch that.
This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]